Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui je voudrais vous parler de ces objet étranges et mystèrieux que l'on appelle les trous noirs
alors je voudrais vous expliquer déja :
qu'est ce que c'est ?
Où est-ce qu'on en trouve ?
Et puis, quelle est la bonne attitude à avoir si jamais vous en croisez un ?
Les trous noirs ont beau être des objets très complexes dont on n'a pas encore fini d'élucider la structure,
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous expliquer qu'on peut comprendre leur existence
grâce à un simple petit calcul qui ne fait appel qu'à de la physique de lycée.
Alors, imaginons que vous soyez sur terre et que vous lanciez une balle de tennis en l'air.
Bon ben la balle va monter jusqu’à une certaine hauteur et puis elle va redescendre.
Si vous lancez la balle plus fort, elle va monter plus haut, mais vraisemblablement, elle va quand-même finir par redescendre.
La question qu'on peut se poser c'est
à quelle vitesse il faudrait lancer la
balle de tennis pour qu'elle ne retombe jamais
c'est à dire qu'elle échappe à
l'attraction terrestre.
Eh bien comme dans la vidéo que j'avais
fait sur le saut à la perche, on peut
arriver à répondre à cette question
en faisant un simple calcul d'énergie.
Quand on lance une balle à une certaine
vitesse, on lui donne une énergie
qu'on appelle l'énergie cinétique
et qui est d'autant plus grande que la
vitesse est élevée.
Cette énergie cinétique, elle va être
dépensée pour vaincre la force de
gravité qui retient la balle sur terre
et à laquelle on peut associer aussi
une énergie :
l'énergie gravitationnelle.
La condition pour que la balle ne
retombe jamais et s'arrache de l'attraction
terrestre c'est tout simplement que
l'énergie cinétique soit supérieure
à l'énergie gravitationnelle.
Alors évidemment il y a des équations
pour exprimer tout ça :
l'énergie cinétique c'est un demi de "m" "v" carré où "v" c'est la vitesse de la balle et "m" sa masse
et l'énergie gravitationnelle c'est petit "m" fois grand "M" "G" sur "R" où grand "m" c'est la masse de la Terre,
"R" c'est son rayon et "G" c'est la constante de gravitation universelle.
Donc si on prend cette équation et
qu'on la tripote un peu, on peut en
sortir que la vitesse minimum que la
balle doit posséder
pour s'arracher définitivement de
l'attraction terrestre
c'est racine de 2 "G" "M" sur "R".
Si vous lancez la balle en dessous de cette
vitesse elle finira par retomber,
si vous la lancez au-dessus de cette
vitesse elle partira dans l'espace et ne
retombera jamais.
Cette vitesse minimum à posséder pour
s'arracher de l'attraction terrestre,
on l'appelle la vitesse de libération
et vous voyez qu'elle dépend de la
masse de la planète et de son rayon
donc on peut s'amuser à essayer de
calculer sa valeur pour quelques
astres bien connus.
Par exemple pour la terre cette vitesse
de libération, elle vaut 11 km par seconde.
C'est vraiment beaucoup hein, vous voyez qu'avant
de lancer une balle à cette vitesse là,
bah, va falloir se lever tôt.
Pour la lune par exemple la vitesse de
libération est plus faible, c'est
seulement 2,4 km par seconde.
Bon c'est pas très surprenant puisqu'on sait que
l'attraction gravitationnelle à la
surface de la lune, elle est plus faible
qu'à la surface de la terre.
Si maintenant on s'amuse à faire le calcul
pour le soleil, on trouve une valeur
beaucoup plus élevée, hein, la vitesse de
libération, elle est de 617 km par seconde,
ça fait plus de deux millions de
km/h.
Maintenant imaginez une planète qui
aurait la masse du soleil
mais qui ne ferait qu'1 km de rayon.
Bon, pourquoi pas après tout, hein ?
Si on s'amuse à calculer la vitesse de
libération à la surface de cette planète
on trouve 515 mille kilomètres par
seconde.
Vous voyez ce qui cloche ? Ouais,
c'est plus que la vitesse de la lumière.
et on sait depuis Einstein que rien ne
peut aller plus vite que la lumière.
Ça veut dire que si vous êtes à la
surface de cette hypothétique planète,
jamais vous ne pourrez vous en échapper.
et ce qu'on a la c'est
une des définitions possibles d'un trou noir :
un trou noir c'est un astre dont la
vitesse de libération
est plus grande que la vitesse de la
lumière,
de sorte que
rien ne peut s'en échapper.
Heureusement pour nous cette situation elle n'est quand-même pas très courante, hein,
vous voyez que la vitesse de libération,
elle est d'autant plus importante que la
masse est importante et que le rayon
est petit, donc elle correspond à
des astres qui sont extrêmement denses,
bien plus denses que les planètes ou les
étoiles normales. Mais on pense que
cette situation peut quand-même se
produire pour certaines étoiles à la
fin de leur vie.
Il faut savoir que quand une étoile a fini
d'épuiser tout le combustible
nucléaire qui lui permet de briller,
elle commence à s'effondrer sur
elle-même et donc elle devient de plus
en plus dense,
et sous l'effet de l'attraction
gravitationnelle, elle se densifie, elle
se densifie et elle peut finir
suffisamment dense pour former un trou noir.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les trous noirs
stellaires.
Alors il faut savoir que c'est pas le seul
scénario possible pour la fin de vie
des étoiles mais on pense que c'est ce
qui se produit
pour les étoiles dont la masse dépasse plusieurs fois la masse du soleil
et d'ailleurs si le destin des étoiles
vous intéresse je vous recommande
d'aller voir les vidéos de la chaîne
"Le sense of wonder"
qui a déjà parlé notamment de la mort
du soleil et des supernovas.
Il y a un point qui est vraiment très
important à comprendre pour bien
percevoir le côté maléfique des trous
noirs,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'être à
la surface de l'astre pour se retrouver piégé.
Il faut savoir que concept de vitesse
de libération,
il ne s'applique pas seulement quand vous
êtes à la surface, mais il s'applique
aussi à proximité de l'astre.
On peut reprendre notre calcul de tout à l'heure, avec une planète qui a un rayon "R" et une masse "M".
Imaginons qu'au lieu d'être à la
surface, vous soyez
à une distance "D" du centre de la planète.
Eh ben on peut refaire exactement le
même calcul que tout à l'heure
sauf que cette fois dans l'énergie
gravitationnelle qu'il faudra vaincre
"R" sera remplacé par "D"
et vous voyez que la vitesse de libération
deviendra racine de 2 "GM" sur "D".
Tout à l'heure on a vu que la vitesse
de libération à la surface de la terre
c'était 11 km par seconde.
Et bien si je me place à 25000 km en
orbite au-dessus de la surface
elle ne sera plus que d'environ 5 km par
seconde.
On peut voir que la vitesse de
libération quand on est à une certaine
distance de l'astre, elle sera toujours
inférieure à ce qu'elle est
quand on est à la surface.
Mais on peut imaginer que si un astre est suffisamment dense et qu'on n'est pas très loin
même si on n'est pas à la surface, la
vitesse de libération puisse être plus
grande que la vitesse de la lumière
et donc on pourrait quand-même se
retrouver piégé.
Alors on peut écrire une condition pour
savoir si on va être piégés ou pas.
Si on a un astre de masse "M",
la vitesse de libération elle sera
supérieure à la vitesse de la lumière
dès qu'on se trouve à une distance
plus petite qu'une valeur critique qui vaut
2 "G" "M" sur "c" carré.
En gros si vous avez un astre de masse
"M" et que vous êtes à distance
inférieure à cette distance critique
de lui,
et ben vous êtes cuit.
Et en fait ça c'est vrai même si le
rayon de l'astre est bien plus petit que
la distance à laquelle vous vous
trouvez.
Donc vous voyez que ce qui compte dans
cette affaire ce n'est pas tellement le
rayon physique de l'astre, c'est plutôt
cette distance critique en dessous de
laquelle on est sûr d'être piégés.
Cette distance critique on l'appelle le
rayon de Schwarzschild de l'astre.
C'est en hommage au mathématicien qui
le premier a résolu les équations de
la relativité générale dans le cas
d'un corps sphérique.
Dès qu'un astre a un rayon physique qui
est plus petit que le rayon de Schwarzschild,
vous avez un trou noir, et donc si vous
êtes à une distance inférieure à ce rayon de Schwarzschild,
même si vous n'êtes pas
sur l'astre et ben vous êtes piégés.
Ce rayon de Schwarzschild, il délimite
donc une surface
Qu'on appelle l'horizon du trou noir.
C'est une frontière immatérielle qui
marque le point de non-retour.
Alors j'insiste sur le fait que cette
frontière elle est immatérielle parce
qu'au niveau de l'horizon du trou
noir, il n'y a rien de spécial.
C'est juste la limite de la zone en
dessous laquelle
vous êtes cuit.
Alors tout ça c'est très bien mais ça reste de la théorie,
d'autant plus que si rien ne s'échappe d'un trou noir, comment on fait pour les observer ?
Alors les trous noirs stellaires, ceux qui résultent de l’effondrement d'une étoile,
on n'en a jamais observé avec une absolue certitude.
On a un certain nombre de très bons candidats dont on ne voit pas très très bien ce que ça pourrait être d'autre que des trous noirs,
mais il subsiste quand-même encore un petit doute.
Par contre, il y a une autre catégorie de trous noirs, dont je n'ai pas encore parlé, et pour lesquels on est beaucoup plus confiants.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les trous noirs galactiques.
Les trous noirs galactiques ce sont des trous noirs géants
dont on pense qu'ils se trouvent au centre
d'à peu près toutes les galaxies,
et notamment de la nôtre : la voie lactée.
Alors si vous voulez contempler un trou noir ou plus ou moins
regarder dans sa direction, vous pouvez
les soirs d'été vous tourner vers le sud
et regarder la trace de la voie lactée
à proximité de la constellation du Sagittaire.
Alors c'est une constellation qui est bien connue
des astronomes amateurs parce que ses étoiles principales
dessinent une sorte de théière stylisée
Et ben légèrement au dessus
du bec de la théière c'est la direction du
centre de la voie lactée. Et c'est là
qu'on trouve un trou noir gigantesque
qu'on appelle Sagittarius A* (A-étoile)
et dont on pense qu'il pèse environ
4 millions de fois la masse du soleil.
Alors là vous allez me dire : comment on est sûr qu'il y a un trou noir
à cet endroit là puisqu'on ne peut pas le voir directement ?
Alors c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas voir directement le
trou noir lui-même, mais il y a 2 choses
qu'on peut observer. La première c'est
la matière qui est autour du trou noir
et qui est en train de tomber vers le trou noir sans
encore avoir passé le point de non-retour.
Cette matière est très fortement accelérée
et ça lui fait émettre des rayonnements électro-magnétiques
qu'on capte en provenance de cette
direction du ciel.
L'autre chose qu'on peut observer, c'est la trajectoire
d'étoiles qui sont très proches du trou noir et qui
tournent autour.
Récemment il y a
des astronomes qui ont analysé la trajectoire de ces étoiles
et ça leur a permis de calculer la masse du trou noir
et d'estimer sa taille.
Maintenant qu'on a vu ce qu'est un trou noir et qu'on sait qu'ils existent
on peut se demander ce qui se passe
si jamais on en croise un.
Et bien si vous croisez un trou noir et que vous commencez à tomber
vers lui, ça ne va pas être très très
mouvementé en fait. Vous allez tomber en chute libre
mais comme il n'y a pas d'air, pour faire des frottements
ça va être très très différent d'une chute libre quand
on tombe d'un avion par exemple.
En fait vous allez tomber et avoir la sensation d'être
en totale apesanteur.
Ca va être plutôt sympa...
Il y a juste un problème dans cette
histoire c'est que si vous tombez par exemple les
pieds devant, vos pieds vont être légèrement
plus proches du trou noir que votre tête,
et donc ils vont subir une attraction gravitationnelle
qui va être un chouïa plus importante
que celle subie par votre tête
Et le problème c'est qu'à force de tomber,
ce chouïa, il va devenir de plus en plus gros
et il va commencer à vous étirer.
Alors, ce phénomène d'étirement c'est ce qu'on appelle la force de marée
Alors, il n'est pas du tout spécifique des trous noirs
et c'est justement lui qui explique le phénomène des
marées sur terre.
Quand la lune est d'un certain côté de la planète elle va
attirer un petit peu plus l'eau qui est proche d'elle
que l'eau qui est loin d'elle, et donc elle va
déformer la surface des océans, et ça va
causer des marées hautes à certains endroits
et des marées basses à d'autres endroits.
Et vous quand vous allez tomber vers
le trou noir, et bien ces forces de marées elles vont
commencer à vous étirer vous étirer vous étirer
jusqu'à vous écarteler.
C'est ce qu'on appelle parfois la spaghettification.
Contrairement à une idée répandue le fait de
se faire spaghettifier n'a absolument rien à voir avec le fait
de franchir l'horizon du trou noir.
La spaghettification peut avoir lieu bien avant
ou bien après l'horizon.
D'ailleurs quand vous allez passer l'horizon du trou noir,
il ne va rien se produire de spécial,
vous n'allez même pas vous en rendre compte.
Par contre si vous avez laissé un pote
en orbite un peu plus loin,
lui, il va voir des drôles de trucs.
Quand vous tombez vers le trou noir, votre copain
il peut vous voir tomber parce qu'il y a des rayons
lumineux que vous émettez et qui parviennent jusqu'à lui.
Et plus vous vous approchez du trou noir
plus les rayons lumineux que vous émettez
vont mettre du temps à lui parvenir.
Et donc lui, il vous verra tomber
de plus en plus lentement.
Et en fait de son point de vue à lui votre chute va
tellement de plus en plus se ralentir
qu'il pourra vous regarder tomber jusqu'à la fin des temps.
En fait il vous verra vous
rapprocher de plus en plus de l'horizon mais
il ne pourra jamais vous voir le franchir.
Ça c'était pour votre pote qui est resté
loin du trou noir et qui est en train de vous regarder.
Par contre, vous, une fois que vous avez franchi
l'horizon ça va commencer à devenir beaucoup moins cool.
Bon déjà vous allez tomber de plus en plus vite,
les forces de spaghettification vont être de plus en plus importantes
et vraisemblablement vous allez vous faire écarteler.
Alors imaginons quand-même que vous arriviez à survivre,
vous allez découvrir que la structure de l'espace-temps
a complètement changé.
Alors c'est quelque chose qui est assez difficile à décrire sans vraiment
regarder les équations, mais il y a quand-même une manière de le comprendre.
Vous savez pour nous sur terre on dit que le temps s'écoule,
ça veut dire que le temps passe
et qu'on peut absolument rien y faire,
on ne peut pas décider de rester à un moment
fixe du temps.
Par contre pour l'espace c'est beaucoup plus simple :
si je veux rester dans une position fixe de l'espace,
personne ne m'en empêche.
Et bien de l'autre côté du trou noir,
c'est impossible de rester à une position
fixe de l'espace.
L'espace s'écoule, un peu de la même
manière que le temps s'écoule pour nous
Ca veut dire que quoi que vous fassiez,
vous tombez inéluctablement vers le centre du trou noir.
Si vous êtes tombé dans le trou noir en étant équipé
d'un jet pack ou alors à bord d'une fusée
avec un moteur,
vous allez peut être être tenté de vous en servir
pour essayer de ralentir un peu votre chute.
Mais en fait c'est une mauvaise idée,
parce qu'on peut montrer que si jamais vous essayez de vous débattre comme ça,
le temps qui vous sépare du centre du trou noir
va se raccourcir.
Si vous voulez que le temps de votre chute vers le centre
du trou noir prenne le plus de temps possible,
en fait la meilleure chose à faire c'est de ne rien faire.
Il faut se laisser tomber en chute libre.
Une fois au centre du trou noir,
il faut avouer qu'on ne sait pas très très bien ce qui se passe.
Alors la théorie de la relativité générale d'Einstein
nous dit qu'au centre du trou noir il y a
un point où la densité et
la courbure de l'espace-temps deviennent infinis,
ce qu'on appelle une singularité.
Sauf qu'en pratique, on se doute
qu'au voisinage de cette singularité
le théorie de la relativité générale toute seule, elle ne marche plus.
Il faut notamment prendre en compte des effets de mécanique quantique,
et pour faire ça correctement, il faut qu'on dispose
d'une théorie qui unifie
mécanique quantique et relativité générale.
Aujourd'hui on n'a pas de théorie comme ça
mais, je vous en ai déjà parlé, il y a plusieurs tentatives.
Il y en a une qui est la théorie des cordes sur laquelle
j'avais fait une vidéo
et il y en a une autre qui est la gravité quantique à boucles
dont je vous parlerai bientôt.
Mais il faut avouer qu'à l'heure actuelle aucune de
ces 2 théories ne donne une réponse vraiment
très très satisfaisante pour savoir ce qui se passe
au voisinage de la singularité,
et à l'heure actuelle les trous noirs n'ont
pas encore livré tous leurs mystères.
Voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui !
Alors comme d'habitude j'ai écrit un petit billet qui accompagne cette vidéo
et qui précise une chose ou 2.
Notamment il faut savoir que l'argument que je vous ai
donné pour justifier l'existence des trous noirs,
celui basé sur la vitesse de libération,
en fait il n'est pas correct.
C'est un argument qu'on appelle "avec les mains".
Mais pour vraiment démontrer que les trous noirs existent,
il faut faire les équations de la relativité générale,
on ne peut pas s'en sortir autrement.
Si vous voulez comprendre où est la faille dans cet argument
et comprendre un peu pourquoi la relativité générale
explique l'existence des trous noirs, vous pouvez
aller lire ce billet.
Un autre billet que j'ai écrit il y a quelque temps et qui
peut vous intéresser se demande si on peut créer
des micro-trous noirs dans le LHC,
vous savez, l’accélérateur de particules du CERN.
Alors a priori il y a peu de chances mais
il y a quand-même une certaine version de la théorie
des cordes qui prédit que
peut-être, au LHC, on pourrait
créer des micro-trous noirs.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo !
Comme d'habitude si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la partager
pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne,
vous pouvez vous abonner, vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux,
Facebook, Twitter.
Ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Merci beaucoup à tous les tipeeers qui me soutiennent,
et vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon blog Science étonnante.
Merci et à bientôt !